Yeah,
it's about 80070 just because I know it a little.
Well, I know it from 1141.
I'm the 55th Sudo Honke's stoneware.
psa boo bar [ __ ] dosan It's a big boo. Ah, that sake brewing super. It's
said that they are deeply involved in life and support various things
.
It protects me from the strong sunlight, and even at the time of that earthquake,
for example, the sound of the tree was underneath, so it softened my confidence, and
voodoo U.S. Mercian was tied up.  In that case
, as soon as I stopped the sake brewing arm, I
analyzed the radioactivity and found that it was nothing, but
since it is also rooted in life in Japanese culture, all lifestyles
are like this.  In a word, Osaka is very elegant
that all the various spirits are contained in the various cultures of my daily life
.
It's not that various Japanese cultures I
don't recommend those good things
ana yeah yeah
yeah